hey everybody i'm dave rubin and today
on the reuben report
i'll be chatting with dr ron paul about
last week's censorship of his facebook
page
the incoming biden administration the
outgoing trump administration
administration and the state of liberty
in the u.s
in 2021 but first i want to tell you
about bonner private wine
anyone here likes to have a drink once
in a while i think you guys know i do
i've got a bottle of wine in my hand
right now and i'd like to share with you
how to make that drink 10 times
healthier
down in argentina they make this really
dark red wine from malbec grapes grown
at 9 000
feet they've lab tested these wines and
found that they contain up to 10 times
the levels of a nutrient called
resveratrol
resveratrol's powerful stuff it pops up
again and again in studies on longevity
heart health and brain health these
wines also have 90 less sugar fewer
chemicals and fewer additives
plus if you love steak and bbq as much
as i do you'll be happy to hear that red
wine has been shown to actually make
red meat healthier but the best part is
the wine
taste with notes of blackberry leather
smoke and a little dark cherry
today the guys at freethinkerwine.com
are giving you 50
off their best malbecs and 50 off
shipping
wine makes a great gift even if it's
just a gift to yourself just visit
freethinkerwine.com today that's
freethinkerwine.com
and now back to me all right today
i am absolutely thrilled guys this has
been about five six years in the making
we tried to do it in person a couple
times it didn't quite work out
you may know that this guy's not
thrilled with the tsa and neither am i
but finally i am talking to author
physician
retired congressman and former
presidential candidate
dr ron paul finally welcome to the
reuben report
thank you dave real nice to be with you
well i'm i'm thrilled to have you
we've obviously wanted to have this
conversation for quite some time i think
you know a bit about
my sort of awakening into the the
freedom space the liberty space um but
to have you on right now the day before
the biden administration comes in we're
wrapping up the trump administration and
with so much going on with tech
censorship and everything else
i thought the timing would be just
perfect so let's just start
last week out of nowhere your facebook
page was suspended now i believe it's
back
but this happened with no warning and uh
you you've been warning about the power
of big tech for quite some time
and of course they said there was no
there was plenty of warning we warned
you
and uh when we inquired about it he said
you've you failed to follow your various
warnings which wasn't true
they they never uh they they never
warned us at all
but the reason they said was that i
don't follow community standards
and i i didn't know about community
standards i wasn't taught that
in college or medical school or any
place i i thought
i thought i thought well that's this
public thing you're a public
official now i said well should i get my
community standards from fox or from cnn
or msnbc where and where do i find these
answers
and i says besides why are you [ __ ]
me i'm no threat to you
i'm just a little outfit you know you
know i'm
poking a little bit of fun at them but
they they of course just don't want
anybody to disagree when if you're
dealing with an idea
and you come across you know he might be
telling the truth then they know you're
a danger
yeah what do you make of the
extraordinary power that
big tech has over us right now that the
founders could have
never imagined a structure so
big sort of above the government that
controls all of our information
well it's terrible but the answer is not
simplistic it's not like just do this
and we can get back to our free market
i had to look at that carefully and i
don't like it anymore anybody else but
i don't like the principle of writing
run one regulation and telling them what
they can do and monitor everything they
do
that certainly isn't a libertarian
answer uh to solving
solving this problem uh but uh
if if one looks at how the internet
developed
and try to understand where did it come
from is it an outgrowth of
free markets and and volunteerism
and i came to conclusion absolutely not
you know the
internet came about some other way and
uh there was a lot of financing a lot of
financing still
continues they get legal protection
you know for what they do so i would say
that
the market is has been pushed aside and
that's where the trouble comes from and
that we should think about
how do you return to the market which is
which is not
easy but i think there's enough
technology
to have have it make it available to
those of us that would like
to have a different uh a different
outlet for our views
and i think the the only way i can think
of is
the principle is is go toward as much
private property as you can
and exclude you know government
regulations and rules
and also uh to
emphasize the issue of uh voluntary
agreements the contract
the contract is what saves the
marketplace voluntary arrangement
get together agree on it and have a
voluntary arrangement
and uh that doesn't exist with it now
and they don't have any part
about it all they want to do is gang up
on us
and act in concert so all the big
tech companies get together and then
they can pile on they're very very
powerful
but i tell you what if you get enough
people who believe in something else
and uh and other people use their
ingenuity and their ability
i think uh we can we can you know
provide the competition that is
necessary
yeah you're speaking my language that's
exactly why i started locals.com and i
think we're talking to your guys about
it
this week did you find that you saw a
lot of libertarians in the last couple
weeks sort of jumping ship on that idea
however because they go well this thing
is just too big and if you can
blow up amazon servers and knock parlor
off
that the idea the very idea of
competition
sort of doesn't exist anymore i heard a
lot of that from libertarians i always
believe that the market and human
ingenuity will solve things
yeah i think that's the best way to
describe it is sort of like they
disappeared
they're not joining the gang and making
fun of us
it's just that they don't want to get
into the debate it's too complicated for
them
and i sort of felt that way at the
beginning because
the first thing i wanted to do was not
interfere
and uh but then i also accepted the
principle that i sort of
observed over the many years is that
when you have trouble like this it
usually involves the government there's
been a couple very good books about
uh you know monopolies and and powerful
organizations and
almost always if not always uh if you
have a
monopoly uh it's going to
need the government to establish it or
protect it
so the uh monopolies that don't come as
a consequence of free market
the main thing there to prevent that
from happening is free entry you know
that you can't prohibit entry but that's
what we're all facing now
that i want to get our information out
uh is that the
entry is getting more and more difficult
because i'm going to let the smart
people that know how to work this
technology
and i want to look at and i want to help
and i want to encourage it
but i also want to emphasize the issue
of private property and volunteerism
because
i believe the answer is there and i
think what we have now is an
outro of way too much government
and uh they get a big tech gets a lot of
funding they make a lot of money off
this thing
and i i would think that's a good way to
maybe limit
to what they can do is don't do business
with them why should the taxpayer
have to do business with these companies
and of course
that's when the people in washington
just crumble
because uh i don't i i suspect you know
david
that both republicans and democrats tend
to
get along with these big corporations
they may fight out on the open
but uh it's a it's bipartisan whether
when i make my complaints i always make
the point you know whether it's monetary
policy spending
deficits war or whatever very bipartisan
no matter what the noise you hear
the bipartisanship is very strong and
that's the reason that we have a problem
is that bipartisanship endorses these
principles of interventionism and
inflationism
and constant wars and uh
too many people trust in the uh
bipartisan system that they can watch
each other
just gets going through these elections
it sounds like only two people at
loggerheads
but uh did do the republicans ever cut
the tax spending
no they usually increase it so this is
the reason people have to look at the
issues
uh and rather than accepting the idea
that this is a a narrow partisan
fight that's going on because that's not
true yeah
somehow they say they disagree on
everything but they always agree on
spending more
and more wars although as trump's
presidency ends tomorrow
he did not start any new wars so
to sort of recap what trump did i mean i
assume you're happy with some cut taxes
getting rid of some regulation
kicking some stuff back to the states
not going to war that all fits
the the libertarian lens uh but spending
did increase
i'm sure you have some other problems
with trump where where do you grade
these four years from a liberty
perspective
well not real well but uh compared to
what
you know compared to others compared
because
that's pretty good right yeah well
but uh some of the things that are
established i would say that we're more
on the verge of
a big serious war with iran so those
things like that
uh bother me uh but no
i would was taking the issue that i've
spent the most time on
in my political career and i think it's
so important because it's so pervasive
and that is the monetary issue in the
federal reserve
it was a disaster there uh in a friendly
way
type of thing you know but but he uh
when when uh he needed the fed to do
something
he was he was a powerful person he had a
lot of influence
and when the establishment and probably
the deep state was the little thing he's
gone
too much i mean this thing is in
shambles we we have to start
uh you know winding down our balance
sheet and that kind of thing
uh but he uh he he said
you're going to get these interest rates
down and he was tough and strong
and he he prevailed so
in some ways if you look at trump and i
agree with the positives that you
mentioned
but if you uh look at what trump did he
he spoke
sort of like a modern monetary theorist
uh you know of what you know it's back
to helicopter money
given what they need it six thousand uh
six trillion dollars of uh debt in this
past year
and it's still coming but now now the
republicans
they'll go back to their roots now they
will be biden deficits
and we can't allow that to happen do you
sense that sort of
the biggest problem for libertarians to
get the messaging out
is that people seem unable to understand
that it's about
spending that it's always the government
is
always spending more and more that it's
just set up to always spend more and
more and more
and even if you they cut taxes a little
bit or they throw
us six hundred dollars a person that it
comes with a package that puts us in
that much more debt that just talking
about spending and debt it's not sexy
enough to sort of get the ideas out
there
in a in a mainstream way yes and it's
very
temporary i consider it's like trying to
uh treat a drug addict by just giving
him more drugs and he feels better
excuse me but that's what happens when
you put the money out there that sort of
helps and makes the economy
feel better i thought our current crisis
started
uh in in 99
uh not in 2000 uh and that was when
when the balance sheet was in in big
trouble and it was
evident that things were going to turn
down if they didn't really really pump
and uh they they capitulated and they
did it
and uh you say well yeah if you took the
other side of the argument
yeah but didn't he save the day didn't
that really rally
if you'd have done nothing wouldn't that
have led to a lot of correction yeah
probably would have but
they've probably been all over by now
but they prevented the bankruptcy
but they delayed the inevitable big
bankruptcy
because they wanted to flood the market
you know with the money
and they could tide it over it
temporarily helps and the drug addict
feels better so there was no hesitation
at all it's never been done before and
now we have a financial bubble
bigger than any other time in our
history is the way i see it
right so now with that in mind going
into a biden administration where
they're
you know promising all sorts of stuff
and we know we're going to see a massive
expansion of government and
half of the swamp people are are all
coming back and there'll be
no program that's too big i mean you
can't be
very hopeful at the moment right
well vaguely so i'm i'm always going to
remain hopeful
or i'd have to do something else uh you
know
other than trying to tell people there's
hope in our message and i know you have
hope and our message
but the big thing is is getting that
that message out
and getting people to understand it no i
see it as an opportunity
uh you know uh you know vietnam war was
a horror until the people spoke out in
the vietnam war ended
but what about i see i remember the cold
war
very very well and i've studied that i
was drafted in 1962
and i was in the service for five five
years
and that was the height of the cold war
but nobody back then
even hit it that they thought well you
know just don't sweat it folks
it's no big deal the soviet system
doesn't work it's
it'll fail and it's going to disappear i
never dreamed that 1989 would arrive in
1990 the wall would come down
and all of a sudden we had a wonderful
opportunity we had improvement
but unfortunately the world went along
with our interventionism inflationism
and
federal reserve stuff and and having
deficit
but i'll tell you we we
i was in the air force and there was a
lot of preparations being made to have a
nuclear exchange
i was drafted you know during the cuban
crisis and just
disappeared so i think this is going to
disappear but i
am worried about what the replacement
are because the people who want to
know it too and they're probably they're
even hurrying it on are those people who
want to disrupt the streets
and and bring this to an end uh so to me
it's an intellectual fight
it's getting the ideas out even when i
see people like you out there
uh past getting out of messaging you
know not even a lot of you're not even
trying to use it
use the words of liberty that's what we
need and
now people people you know just think of
all those restaurant tours in
italy thousands and thousands out enough
is enough
we're open for business and i think that
can happen
and so i think of people now you know
like the mises institute i think louis
rockwell has done a fantastic job
and uh i i uh you know did
did i did do a little bit of campaign in
the presidential campaign and sort of
it sort of was surprised anybody cared
uh so young people frequently wouldn't
come up to me after so
oh i'm excited about this so what do i
do tell me what i do should i run for
office and all that and i said
do whatever you want to do and so many
so many have you might not have been in
that category but you did what you want
to do
and now you have a voice it is an
intellectual problem it's an ideal
ideological problem to get an answer out
and a message out
because things don't happen out of the
clear blue and uh
the people on the streets didn't just
think it up
and you know i would say i tell people
it's ideal ideology that's important
what about when these wars start why do
they sport and support why do they get
started
i said young people in america don't get
together with the young people in europe
or
asia and talk to each other and say you
know what
we're 18 now wouldn't it be neat if we
had a war
because let's go ahead and start a war
they're the last people that want a war
and yet the ideology of keynesianism and
socialism and welfare isn't
because government is forced the bigger
the government the more force it is
that's why i'm so strongly uh in favor
of
gun control of the people and
governments we need to regulate their
guns
because that the gun is used to impose
the system on us
you know no matter what they do and tell
us and all the programs that are coming
are always enforced with government guns
and uh that's the kind of a
force that we have to resent but
defensive force is
of course uh obviously proper and
necessary
in a free society yeah you gave me a
couple of ways to go there so
uh first on on the force part of it i
mean have you seen the images coming out
of dc the last couple days
25 000 troops on the ground walls being
built
i mean basically a ghost town it's just
unbelievable
that says scare the people and tell
people who's really in charge
and the other people you know the the
ones that were there
uh their propaganda stuff went perfectly
because
when i say this this is one of those
risky things you don't say on the
internet people aren't supposed to
realize it
but it was uh it was related
to donald trump and the people that
support him but you know the
ruthlessness i just don't believe it you
know i may be wrong
and i think it's up for discussion i
just wish they'd allow more
investigation
you know whether it's for the election
or what happens under these conditions
but the whole thing is is uh uh
there was a a use of force but it
compared to what what happened when they
marched into the capital
compared to the armed forces that we see
now
how about the 250 000 plus
bureaucrats who carry a gun to enforce
all the regulations
you know and collect the taxes and uh
tell us what to do i mean
there's hundreds of thousands carrying
guns
and that's not a good excuse for
claiming that we have a free society at
the same time
we have to get rid of the second
amendment the problem is
the people have too many guns well i
think we have too much
government i wouldn't decide that we can
have the bureaucracy and no guns in the
government
we need a lot less people there we have
a much should have a much smaller
bureaucracy
and it should go with it should be
automatic that they shouldn't be
carrying guns to enforce laws that
shouldn't even be on the books
you are speaking my language so so you
mentioned that i'm not afraid to say the
word liberty i i describe myself at this
point as a radical
freedom extremist so so there you go
uh but to even have these conversations
online i mean the way you said the thing
about the election just for a second
that you would have just liked more
uh investigations or whatever even that
i don't that doesn't seem incendiary to
me or anything else
it's getting harder and harder to even
say okay i just want to have a
discussion about that
not even say that there's something
wrong yeah
that's all that's all we should be
asking for because we believe we can
stand up against their ideas
what about me as a physician and
somebody in politics
and then we we look at coronavirus and
the worst thing you can do is take a
medical position
that contradicts the people who want the
lockdown
well you can get into a lot of trouble
with that and yet uh
science has settled it even today i
think i mentioned in my program science
you know science had trouble settling
the fact that they thought the earth was
flat
people lost their lives people lost
their lives over there
and in medicine uh you know since i've
studied medicine
there's been a lot of things in medicine
that were wrong
uh they contradicted even some things
some of the things that i was taught
in the 1950s about obstetrics uh
turned out not to be right we used to
have a saying once a c-section always a
c-section but it took somebody else it
took people who were
not in the official medical profession
to to challenge those things that's what
we went we want challenge and
competition
and ideas and we we have to be able to
discuss it
when you can't discuss it that becomes
the problem it isn't
it isn't whether i'm right or wrong or
or somebody else is wrong
about how you take care of of a virus
and uh because there are two different
ways to do it anywhere from you
uh you know build up an industry that
can make a couple bucks on vaccines
or or whatever but uh you should have
the discussion and that's what they're
preventing
that's why dave keep it going you have
to stay on there and i hope you build a
big audience
that's the plan my friend all right i
have one more for you and then we're
going to go to
the first time i've ever done it i
normally don't do audience
questions but i just knew how many
people were going to want to ask you
things so i figured
we'd grab one but you you've hit on this
a little bit you talked about what's
going on in italy now with
all 50 000 restaurants opening up and
people are just saying enough's enough
so br i know your feelings on the
lockdown anyone watching this can figure
out your feelings on lockdowns
but are you surprised how quickly
everyone
gives up freedoms gives up the ability
to leave their houses
gives up their ability to make money and
go to work and do all the things that
give us dignity and purpose
and that we just continually you know
like two weeks to flatten the curve
it's literally almost a year later at
this point does that
concept does that shock you or not at
this point
well it uh bothers me
uh and um it's annoying
but i'm not totally shocked by it i am
impressed how pervasive you know these
doctrines which have been preached for
30 40 50 years
in our universities that's where the
source of all this comes from so i
expected it
but i i was impressed with how pervasive
how worldwide has been especially
dealing with the coronavirus
but that uh that to me i just flipped
the coin
i said yes but i've already made the
example
of the soviet system you know it ran out
of steam
and how can how can what they're doing
now do you think
interventionism is going to be maine
will be made you know universally
acceptable
and wonderful people are going to be
happy and the poor won't be poor
and and uh there will not be a division
of wealth that we have
no that that's going to be around and
that's what orlando it's this
male distribution of wealth and this is
certainly related to the monetary system
that is here and that's why it's going
to force a change
the big thing is you'll say well you
know for sure
how do you know it might not get worse
well that's the problem it may get worse
before it gets better
but i tell you what the only thing that
can address it
will be address it in intellectual terms
and show that you know and we hear the
words
what do you guys want to do you want to
live like venezuela
but that's not a lot to be on the news
you know and you can't talk about that
and that's that's a terrible thing to
say but people will come around to that
and they're going to realize it but it's
up to us
and it's up to other people because
there may be a few people listening to
us today
that doesn't have their own program they
say oh yeah that's damn guy he's a
brilliant guy
he has a great program on he gets on tv
and they said they threw up their hands
but i'll tell you what
i've seen some young people come up with
amazing ideas
and be more creative than they ever even
knew they were
but they have to have a belief in
something and they have to be energized
to do something
and they do have to have a bit of sense
that ideas are important and good ideas
can stamp out bad ideas ah well said
well said all right so here's the
audience question for you and then i
know you've got a busy day so we're
going to let you go i'm going to get you
in a little
hot water probably with your family at
the moment because the question from
cody g in the reuben report locals
community
is will dr paul encourage his son
rand to run for president in 2024
well i'll tell you what i tell him what
i just told all the young people that
ever came up to me
do whatever you want you know i know
i know my son and i don't know where he
learned it but he's very
independent-minded
and he's very well read and uh he knows
a little bit about politics because i
think i
uh i hinted to him when he decided
to step into the political arena he was
going to run for the senate
and i sort of generally said are you
sure you want to run for the senate to
start off with shouldn't you
take it a little bit easy no i know
better than that so
my answer is is i'm very libertarian on
that he'll make up his own mind
but i will have to admit that uh
when all things are equal if if he does
run and we aren't winning the fight that
we're talking about here
it would uh it would worry me a bit
because conditions are so lousy
and uh and i've seen especially the
anti-war faction in this country
it's a very deadly challenge the
pro war pro pro peace candidate
the kennedys or martin luther king is
very very dangerous in that sense
so but otherwise everything we do in
life is uh is a little bit dangerous so
and rand would say yeah i've already
been shot at on the baseball field
i've already had my neighbor attacked me
so he would say it's already dangerous
and i guess he was accounts to a coast
to accustom in the war in the streets of
washington no and the answer is he'll do
what he has
he'll do what he feels he has to and
that's what everybody should do
but friend i know has studied hard and
understands
understands the morality of liberty but
that's what i tell young people
know your subject study it look into the
mises institute
know exactly why for markets are helpful
to poor people
that in itself is a message that has to
be heard but today
the poor people still believe it's
because the rich people are there
it's all because of that free enterprise
system no
it's uh very much uh intertwined with
corporatism where the corporations have
joined the government
to abuse our rights and that is the
challenge
but the information is there the
internet is there you're working on it
yourself today
and this is important that the internet
be preserved
and new ideas come up i saw something
today
about a bitcoin might be an
old-fashioned idea i said i'm just
trying to learn what bitcoin's all about
i would they would say bitcoin might be
an old idea
so there's always going to be a new idea
technology one of my biggest laments
that i've written about
is technology is fantastic when you
think of just the 20th century
with all the war and all the killing
just think about
how many people's lives have been
improved just think of the people who
are
you know causing all the crisis in this
country and are
causing riots and everything else
because they've been
they've their rights have been abused
that category of people the very very
poor in this country
are probably wealthier than 90 of the
population of the world in a hundred
years there's still a lot there
but my big beef is technology is
tremendously helpful
the modern age industrial revolution and
now the computer
really really does help uh tremendously
but my beef is
that so much of it ends up in the
control of the government
and the government uses this technology
to fight
wars and build new weaponry and that's
where
that's where the real threats come from
and real problems that they have
but the technologies there could improve
the standards of the people and until we
understand the importance of a
non-aggressive society
you know no aggression against other
people no lying cheating stealing or
killing one rule there
and the world would be a real blessing
for the most number of people ever known
congressman you know how to end an
interview like a pro
and i just want to say truly this was an
absolute thrill i have no doubt that
that we'll do
it again either on these pipes or or
hopefully in person maybe i'll get to
texas
uh soon enough that we could do it in
person but you've been fighting
the fights that i think are the right
fights for for a long time before me and
you
you opened up the world so a guy like me
could get interested in this movement
and uh and i'm just thrilled to chat
with you and and be fighting alongside
you so thanks for taking the time
and and we'll talk soon great to be with
you
all right guys uh i'm gonna continue for
a few more minutes i i know we probably
could have done six hours uh with ron
paul obviously and it's like man he's
been doing this stuff
just forever and led that tea party
movement that was
that was called racist and bigoted and
tea baggers and all of the awful things
they said about them on cnn and they
were insurrectionists you may remember
that you know what was that about 10
years ago
um about i think it was 2008 right that
was when he ran for president if i'm not
mistaken
and uh and there were there was massive
rallies and they were just
all the worst things were said about
these people does that sound kind of
familiar and really all these people
cared about was the constitution and
freedom and liberty
and the rest of it and it's like his
message is still as clear as it's ever
been
and and i really love this idea that he
said that that is something that i've
been trying to
get out for the last few months here
which is that
the bad ideas will crumble and the good
ideas will win
like if your if your ideas are wrapped
up and we hire people not on their skill
but on their skin color
or you know we're going to just grow at
the ever-growing state and we're going
to take from the people produce and give
to these other people like
those things will crumble it's going to
take time and it's like how bad can it
get before it gets better
but the challenge for all of us right if
you if you care about freedom at any
level if you care about liberty at any
level if you care about your own life to
live it the way you see fit at any level
it's like human ingenuity is the answer
and then we should have
and this is exactly what ron paul was
talking about we should have then
those debates right we should be able to
discuss
all of this stuff because obviously the
pure
conservative is going to have a little
more desire for government than the pure
libertarian and by the way
i completely get all of you guys that
say that
that trump should have done something
about big tech when he had the chance
if that makes sense to me that's not the
pure libertarian perspective
senator paul or sorry congressman paul
wouldn't even want that now
knowing that he was booted temporarily
from facebook last week but what a rich
place to have a conversation
about what do you do if this giant
structure is trying to crush all the
competition can competition still exist
like that's a great debate to have
by the way you can have that debate
pretty pretty openly and honestly with a
lot of people on the right right now
that's why i keep saying what i think
the future of america if it is to be
free at any level
will be a sort of center-right future
you're gonna have your traditional
conservatives then you're gonna have the
more
libertarian wing of conservatism that's
where someone like me
would would fall then you're gonna have
your more religious conservatives and if
we can just sort of
agree to disagree on oh we don't have to
fully believe absolutely everything the
same on every little policy and
regulation here
or this or that or even abortion or
whatever it might be but but we
basically want to live in the same
country well that'll be a hell of a lot
better so it's it's kind of everybody
versus the wokesters and i i like our i
like our chances in that regard
uh guys real quick before we wrap and
then by the way we'll be doing regular
shows all week obviously tomorrow
is going to be quite a day politically
hopefully it will be completely peaceful
let's talk about ideas let's not kill
each other let's not bring political
violence let's not condone political
violence
um and our work is just starting it
really is just starting so anyway
we're live all week and then we've got a
panel on
friday which i'm not gonna i'll tease
the guests tomorrow how about that
because we've got two of the three
settled we're waiting on one more but
it's going to be a great panel
we're going to try to do those those
friday panel shows going forward because
i know you guys loved it and i actually
fully enjoyed it um and then maybe
there'll be some other surprises
throughout the week
but real quick guys it's a new year and
if you're looking for a new protein bar
i've got one in my hand what are the
chances bill bar is the secret to
keeping you both
to keeping both of your new year's
resolutions eating healthier food and
eating tastier food
goal bars are low calorie low sugar high
protein high fiber
great for the keto diet i can actually
lose or maintain weight
while indulging in a yummy treat healthy
has never been this delicious
built bars taste like candy and come in
18 amazing favors
flavors as you know i like that cookies
and cream built bars are covered in 100
chocolate include both
nut and nut free flavors and are soft
and easy to chew
after the holidays we still want to
indulge but we also need to shed those
additional
pounds myself included which is why bilt
bars are the perfect alternative to pie
for the health conscious
guy and in the coconut almond flavor
you're getting 18 g's of protein 180
calories
five grams of sugar and five net carbs
not bad don't give up on your resolution
billbar is the answer go to billbar.com
and use promo code ruben to get 20
off your next order use promo code ruben
for 20
off at builtbar.com
and uh that's all i got for you today
join us
at locals.reubenreport.com we're
building something really great guys and
trust me everybody's reaching out to me
right now right
like this parlor thing which i would
have preferred not happen the sort of
implosion of parlor and of course i do
believe it will come back
and they'll have some more security and
tighten some things uh it's it's
actually at the same time though created
a great opportunity
to shine some light on locals we're
getting a lot of good press i'm getting
calls from vcs and all sorts of money
people that want to help us grow
our our growth is like hockey sticking
right now
and we're building small communities
uh where you own the stuff and you
control the content
and there's a paywall so there's no bad
actors there's no hate
or any of it it's it's like social media
but completely the reverse
all right guys join me at 11 a.m pacific
2 p.m eastern tomorrow for my live
reaction to the biden
inauguration and lord only knows what
else will happen
have a great day everybody
you